[Music]
well sir there's no easy way to say this
um your wife isn't who she says she
is let me tell you what I see
trouble
trouble I
see a woman who outsmarted two
kidnappers
are you okay
ma'am never do you
mention she is a
tiger she's claiming it never happened
never what now she's a wolf and sheep's
clothe in that one honestly I'm
embarrassed by all the
fuss there is no one on God's green
earth who is a greater enforcer of the
laws of this land than Roy
Tillman why do I feel like there's a
butt here but you any Weaponry back
there got an air
[Music]
horn All you people sneaking around here
pretending you're so nice but I know who
you really are I'm a winner that don't
sound accurate I'm a winner yeah my
[Music]
ass better sleep with both eyes open
cut it out cut it out cut it out cut it
out it's good to see you again Mrs lion
that wasn't me first of all I recognize
you you were kidnapped and for the
record that's just reality with all due
respect we've got our own reality you
can't that's not a
thing fx's Fargo premieres November 21st
on FX stream on
Hulu
[Music]
ch